prince harry and meghan markle are
speaking out about the urgent crises in
afghanistan and haiti i encourage you
all to get involved if you can on
tuesday the duke and duchess of sussex
released a statement through their
archwell foundation first addressing the
taliban takeover in afghanistan that's
happening for the first time in 20 years
as the us military continued its plan to
withdraw causing many to flee the
country the couple writes quote as we
all feel the many layers of pain due to
the situation in afghanistan we are left
speechless megan and harry also say
they're heartbroken over the devastating
earthquake and tropical storm affecting
those in haiti quote when any person or
community suffers a piece of each of us
does so with them whether we realize it
or not and although we are not meant to
live in a state of suffering we are
conditioned to accept it the duke and
duchess are encouraging others to join
them in supporting a number of
organizations doing critical work like
megan and harry several stars are
following suit in hopes of raising
awareness and providing relief it was
important to me to share cardi b took to
twitter letting her followers know that
she's got a soft spot for haiti because
they go through so much asking god to
cover the land and their people i gotta
tell them the truth tennis pro naomi
osaka who is of haitian descent also
tweeted in support of the country
writing i'm about to play a tournament
this week and i'll give all the prize
money to relief efforts for haiti i know
our ancestors blood is strong will keep
rising prince harry also shed more light
on the taliban takeover in afghanistan
on behalf of his invictus games
foundation which he founded in 2014 to
help wounded service men and women
around the world many of whom have
served in afghanistan we encourage
everybody across the invictus network
and the wider military community to
reach out to each other and offer
support for one another we must look
beyond ourselves with empathy and
compassion for those we know
and those we don't but this isn't the
first time prince harry has encouraged
the world to come together back in may
he took the stage at the vax live
benefit concert in an effort to call on
world leaders to make sure covet 19
vaccines are accessible for all this
pandemic will not end
unless we act collectively
with an unprecedented commitment to our
shared humanity
the vaccine must be distributed to
everyone
everywhere
we cannot rest
or truly recover
until there is fair distribution to
every corner of the world the duke of
sussex also encouraged everyone to
practice empathy for those who have
struggled during the pandemic in reality
and especially with this pandemic
when any suffer
we all suffer
we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy and compassion for those we know
and those we don't
we need to lift up all of humanity and
make sure that no person or community is
left behind